[Musique]
lundi c'est incroyable et puis c'est
moins dur que fière parce que hier on
avait mal ses débuts et où là on
commence à s'habituer
malgré l'altitude mais ça va
[Musique]
c'est incroyable paysage temps de nous
parce que l'été c'est immense et
magnifique c'est ce qu'on n'a jamais vu
quoi c'est nouveau et puis bah hier
c'était plus compliqué la journée parce
que ben on se mettait en route ont
réveillé les muscles tout mais
maintenant bas c'est souhaite parce que
on a un bon rythme mais tous ensemble et
on s'amuse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
depuis que vos j'ai mal à l'épaule et du
coude le climat ne signe de la muscu léo
est là et je métier de temps en temps et
avec les sox cette ville
je me fais masser ça fait du bien jim et
elle me fait mal comme mos mais là c'est
que le début aux récents mondiaux pour
moi qui la font vraiment encore plus
haut du corps lui très important d'être
bien physiquement ça commence à
avoir des petits bobos alors c'est
beaucoup dé douleur des pôles ou de dos
surtout à cause du port du sac là donc
on arrive à deuxième journée de marche
effectivement il ya aussi des petites
douleurs de genou mais pour ce qui est
bien c'est pourtant n'y a pas de
blessures pas tendance rien donc ça
c'est plutôt chouette les et sûrement il
faut fermer tout ce moment parce que
quand on a fait une grosse journée au
niveau intensité musculaire il ya quand
même des petites lésions ne faut pas non
plus aller trop fort dans les tirs -
c'est vraiment gentil mot pour faire du
bien
à savoir
[Musique]
nous
où
oh
vous
et
[Musique]
vraiment très très mal à la tête mais je
suis fier d'être arrivé comme en
bas au début c'était tranquille après
j'ai commencé à avoir mal à la tête et
du cou ça commence à être un peu
énervant mais c'est après s'est passé
j'ai bu l'eau et j'ai bien su protéger
je trouve et des coûts et c'est vrai
c'était fatigant c'était long mais je
suis arrivé ça l'important
c'est vrai que c'est difficile à cause
des montées
et comment elle est temps de repos
comment parce qu'il fallait vraiment pas
enchaîner mais trouver le bon rythme
et là il fait froid qu'il fait froid là
le collègue le soleil va se coucher du
coup et g2 plus gaza a plus la de doute
vous voilà mais franchement ça va j'ai
un peu mal à la tête mais avec la
duchesse est vrai que c'est normal
franchement c'est beau c'est magnifique
vraiment y'a pas ça à la réunion c'est
un autre paysage est pas mal pas mal
[Musique]